pourquoi
[Musique]
la malchance on quitte à marquer c'est
quoi
[Musique]
jusqu'en mai à l'enseigné
il y avait
aussi
des deux
matches je tenais pas les paroles ouais
alors bien sûr on est hub
zizou ce crysis 2 ya
le deuxième
c'était
une chanson qui a été beaucoup de
personnes un baiser
beaucoup de personnes à draguer sauf moi
parce qu'on veut pas mais ici sur sa
chanson
c'est tout
et
je me suis rendu compte vingt ans après
que la plupart des français pensaient
que c'était la chanson d'amour quand
c'est un sens aux politiques
allaient gaz à d'être bête like this
same
you please send sens
la
[Musique]
scène est
d'office
silent comme chapeau
le dj
[Musique]
continent c'est bien c'est l'épreuve
quoi et le plus grosse épreuve c'était
comme tu me le faire mon papa non
banques non parce que c'est un truc de
studio qui fait
essaye nage peux pas c'est impossible je
peux le dire mais je peux aussi le
bancor
hockey
des mariages bon la seule chanson que tu
sais jouer
parker du début à la fin comme il faut à
depuis ta
chanson d'amour huawei est en santé
[Musique]
oh
le bruit par
[Musique]
binôme est
là
[Musique]
voilà matériel it shows du québec à se
reprocher le très long
[Musique]
tu démarres tour la pac est prêt
on
la vague est
[Musique]
un mélo
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux